Write a polynomial to express
the total value of p $20
bills, q $10 bills,
and r $5 bills.
So what's the value
of p $20 bills?
Well if I have p $20 bills,
the value of each of those
dollar bills is going
to be $20.
So the value all p of them
is going to be 20p.
If I have one $20
bill, it's $20.
If I have three $20 bills, if p
is 3, it's going to be $60.
Actually, let me do that
in the same color as
I underlined it.
I underlined it in yellow.
So let me do the p $20 bills.
So 20p is the p $20 bills.
Then you have your
q $10 bills.
So what's the value of those?
Well it's going to be 10q.
If I have one $10 bill,
it's worth $10.
If I have ten $10 bills, if q
is 10, this is going to be
worth 10 times 10. $100.
And then finally you have your r
$5 bills, which are going to
be worth 5r dollars.
One $5 bill, worth $5.
Two $5 bills, worth $10.
And we're done.
We've expressed it
as a polynomial.
Polynomial just means that we
have multiple terms here and
this is three terms. We could
even call it a trinomial.
Polynomial is a more general
term for more than one term.